family and I'm length and this is
Earth's Mightiest show bub a bonus
that's right for everyone who's been
loving Marvel Studios black pan that
we've got an exciting special extra for
you yeah well you might not have been
able to get your hands on the film just
yet you've definitely been able to blast
Kendrick Lamar's Black Panther the album
like we have it's incredible I've had it
on repeat since February
let's show in a first look anywhere
we're gonna bring to you a music video
for the track pray for me with Kendrick
Lamar and the weekend created with some
amazing footage from the film yeah check
it out
[Music]
from
the
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I fight the world I fight you I fight
myself who need a hero hero you need a
hero look in the mirror that we saw a
prophecy and if I gotta be sacrificed
for the greater good and this wedding
[Music]
mm-hmm it just feels right you know what
I mean yeah all the good song and also I
love the cut together studio footage but
also those animations are really cool oh
that animation is it goes so perfectly
with the color motif of black panther
and the sound of the song it's it's
beyond work it's so good so good and if
you guys want to see more things that
are so good for Marvel Studios Black
Panther you can buy it now available all
over the places and make sure to follow
Earth's Mightiest show find us at
marvel.com
YouTube and social media we're here each
week bringing you cool exclusives
behind-the-scenes hijinks celebrity
interviews and tons of fun stuff with a
dose of Marvel fan
[Music]